So today, we're going to have
an introduction to big data.
So can you put your hands
up, in the audience--
and I'm going to do my best to
have a look-- if you're working
with big data at the moment.
OK.
So that's about a
third of the room.
And I'm blind.
There we go.
All right, so I
have an impression.
So a little story about
big data to start with.
You probably all know
Google Street View.
So when we were
having these cars
driving around taking pictures
so we could have this nice--
there's a great story about how
Street View actually started.
I'll save that for another day.
But if you Google it and
Google Larry in Street View
and how it all started, I'm
sure you'll find a nice story.
When we were doing that, we
were just basically trying
to capture those
images so we could
create this nice experience.
What we didn't really
think about at the time
was how much data we
were actually capturing.
So I think I'm going to
move on to the next slide.
And here, we're going to look
at what kind of information
is already in that image.
And, obviously, in the
years after Street View,
when we started to supply
information on which way--
with traffic and
things like that,
which signs, where the
addresses are, what's going on.
So there's all this
information there.
So this is quite
a rich data set.
And you can imagine that
if you have this data,
you can already start to do
something very useful with it
if you can somehow get
to the information that's
stored in there.
So that's a little
story to start with.
So big data applications.
Some of them involve a
human, and others don't.
What does that mean?
So let's think about
an application that
involves a human, for
example, if you're
running some kind of
experiment and you're
trying to see what users
are actually doing.
So you say, well, you know,
if we get this feature,
do we actually you get
some response from that?
Is it proving to be successful?
And so you're actually
looking at their interaction.
Others might not necessarily
involve human interaction.
Might be, for example, blocking
fraudulent transactions.
So, for example, we're looking
at credit cards coming in,
transactions, and we want to
know which ones are actually
valid or fraudulent.
So we might build a
model or something,
and actually start
processing that data.
And you can imagine
how much data
you might have coming at you
as a bank with all these credit
card transactions
going on all the time.
So there's a couple of examples
of big data applications,
or, let's say, use cases.
Today, we're going to actually
look at four different tools
that we can use from
Google Cloud's Suite which
will actually help us do
something with big data.
So we're going to look
at how we analyze data.
We're going to look at
how we can prepare data.
how we can process it.
We're actually going to look
at some of the end results,
how we can actually
start using that
in dashboarding, for example,
and also how we might actually
leverage the skills
of a data scientist
to actually interact
with that data to create,
for example, a machine
learning model.
So this is a little something
to think about, about big data
as well.
Because when you talk to
people out there, they say,
well, I'm not doing
anything with big data.
I have a database.
There's a terabyte of
information in there.
It's not a lot.
But then, let's have a think,
like, what kind of data
do you have, actually,
at the moment.
So this is the data that
you analyze now, today,
and that data is probably,
like I said, in a database.
It might be up to a terabyte
or something like that.
It's well structured,
quite well.
Your business intelligence
teams are probably
working with it quite a lot.
So you've got a good grip
on what that actually is.
There could be data
that you collect,
but you don't actually
process or analyze.
So you could be collecting logs
from your website application,
for example, server logs, which
are telling you what things are
happening, what users
are clicking on,
what page users start
off on, and where
they move to throughout
that journey on the website.
But you might not be
processing that, for example.
And then there's data that
you're not even collecting.
So maybe in those
logs, you're only
collecting at a certain
level, and you're not actually
keeping all of the
information because it's
too expensive to
store or something.
And then also, on
top of that, there's
data you can actually
acquire from third parties.
So what would be a
good case in this?
So let's say you're doing
something with recommendations,
and you want to get some
information about seasonality,
what's happening with the
weather, is there a correlation
there?
You're probably not going
to go and stick sensors
up all around the world.
Someone else is
doing that for you.
So you probably buy that data,
find some way of acquiring it,
so you can bring it
into your ecosystem
to start doing this thing.
As going back to that
first image, when
we took those photos, there was
already a lot of information
there.
Once you find out the
use cases and start
looking at what
data could be there
and how you could
discover that, then you
can think more about
what you might actually
want to do with that data.
So we're going to start off
with some of the challenges.
And the first one is how to
develop big data pipelines.
So we're going to talk
about a UI application
that we've created called
Google Cloud Dataprep.
It was launched this year.
And it's a tool that basically
allows your analysts and data
scientists to actually interact
with raw data, to clean it up,
to process it, and, actually,
to get it into a database
where they can
start analyzing it.
So one of the challenges--
before I joined Google, I headed
up a business intelligence team
for a number of years.
And one of the challenges
that the team would have,
especially the
analysts on the team,
was when we didn't have
enough development capacity
to build pipelines.
Some of the analysts and
some of the data scientists,
they wanted to start
experimenting, creating models,
and coming up with
some information
to tell their
business users what
was going on with the products
and that kind of stuff.
But because we hadn't
processed that data yet,
they won't be able to
make those insights.
So having some
kind of tool where
they can kind of self service,
where they can actually
go in there and process that--
look at that data, process it.
And key to this is that
once they've actually
had a look at that
data and played around
with a sample of it,
whatever we create there
that we can actually
apply at scale
and use it to process all
that data that they might want
to use in the data warehouse
for their next steps,
or the analysis, or
the data science.
So we're going to look
at two data sets, one
that the data set at the
bottom is ad impressions.
And this is basically some
data stored in the CSV file.
And as the red highlight
is highlighting,
we want to extract
some information there
which is the product ID.
So that is something you
might see on a web URL.
Someone goes to a page and
the product ID is there.
But we need to get at that ID.
The other thing
that we want to do
is we want to look
at some transactions.
And these transactions
are restoring a BigQuery.
And if you're
interested in BigQuery--
I'll probably say this again
somewhere later in the talk--
but if you're
interested in BigQuery,
stick around for the
next talk because it's
when I was going to give us
a great talk about BigQuery.
So we will only be touching
on that very lightly
during this talk.
But in BigQuery, in this
particular data set,
we have some transactions.
And what's actually
quite special
about these transactions is
that we're storing, in BigQuery
itself, nested data.
So one of the things that
you can do with BigQuery
is not just store
your flat table,
but you can actually have,
within each row, a collection.
So think about order and
order lines, or a transaction
and transaction lines.
So we have a transaction
with the different lines,
with the transaction lines,
and we want to get to all--
and at the transaction
line level,
we're storing the product key.
And that's what
we want to get at.
So what we're basically going
to try and do in this data set,
we're going to try to
join the two together.
And we want to
create one data set
where we can look at which
ad impressions actually
resulted in the transaction.
And maybe we want
to look at the time
between those two or something.
So we're going to attempt
to do this now in a demo
without actually
writing any code.
So that's the goal of Dataprep.
So we're going to
switch over to a demo.
This is Cloud Dataprep.
It's accessible via
the cloud console.
And we're going to start off--
I've imported two data
sets to save time.
The top one is the CSV,
and this other data
set here, the scale 2, is
our data set from BigQuery.
So we're going to
go to flows here.
And here is where you
basically create and you flow.
So once you've imported
those data sets,
here is when you're going
to start working with them.
So we're going to
create a new flow demo.
Please be kind.
We're going to add a
couple of data sets here.
So I'm adding the
CSV, and I'm adding
the sales scaled dataset.
So here is the sales scaled
that's coming from BigQuery,
and here's a CSV.
And you can already see
here, I dropped the CSV,
but some action has
already occurred.
So basically what Dataprep
is doing is creating recipes.
And those recipes
is basically what
you need to do to cook your
data from raw to something--
well, cooked-- that
you can start using.
So let's have a look at
what is already suggested.
Well, it was a CSV.
So it understood
that it was a CSV.
So it looked at the delimiter.
So there's a certain amount
of intelligence and machine
learning behind this to
actually do some of this stuff.
And you'll see in a moment how
powerful some of that can be.
It's already come
up with a suggestion
you can see here on the right.
So it's actually worked out
the type of columns that it is.
Let's go and have it edit
our recipe for a moment.
Keeping an eye on the
time in the meantime.
There we go.
So what do we see here?
We've basically got all of
the columns extracted for us.
You can see, for
each column, it's
already suggested a data type.
So this one is alphanumeric.
This one is a number.
And here we have a data/time.
And we've got the
distribution of the data.
So basically, the
data set I imported
was a CSV in a Cloud
Storage bucket.
If there had been
multiple CSVs there,
it would basically be able
to import all of those.
And you see at the top here,
this is quite a small data set.
So it's just picking
the whole data set
because that fits quite nicely.
But if it wasn't,
you could actually--
if it was a bigger data set, we
could collect a random sample.
So we use different
sampling techniques
to actually have a
look at that data,
but since we have all of it
here, that's easy enough.
So we can see here the
distribution of the data.
And it's going into
different columns.
And one of the columns here,
the event time, if I look here,
I can see that there's some data
which is actually a little bit
problematic.
What is it saying.
Let's have a look.
So you notice, all I did
was click here on that data.
So I just clicked on
that little red mark.
So Dataprep is really
the kind of GUI
where you have to
just click around,
and it kind of works
out what you're doing.
So I clicked here
on this red part
because that looked odd
to me, and it came up
with a suggestion.
It came up with
several suggestions.
One of them is that--
so let's have a
look at this one.
This one here is saying, I'm
going to delete the rows.
So delete where it doesn't
conform to a timestamp.
So there was a text
in there, timed out,
or something like that.
But actually, it's coming
up here and saying, well,
the rest of the dates
conform to this pattern.
So let's use this pattern.
And you can go ahead here
and edit that if you want,
but I'm quite happy with this.
So I'm going to add
it to the recipe.
And over here on the right, you
can see the little open recipe.
And you see those
steps that you needed
to do to go from the CSV
file into the columns,
and this new step that we
just added to delete the rows.
You can see that
they're all here.
So break the rows using the
new line as a delimiter.
We're going to split
into columns on comma.
We're going to convert
the first row to headers.
And then we're going to delete
all the rows where it doesn't
match our date/time timestamp.
So we have those.
But I said we wanted
to look at the URL.
And we wanted--
specifically, we want
to get that product
ID out there.
So if we look here,
here's that product ID.
So what I'm going
to do-- as I said,
you have to click and show
it what you want to do.
So I didn't quite get all
of that information there.
So something-- I'm not really
good with a mouse, There we go.
So I selected that.
And it's come up with
some suggestions.
What's it saying here?
It's saying, do I want
to replace PID equals
114-- blah with empty string.
That's not really useful.
No, I mean what--
I'm not extracting anything.
So let's try something else.
Let's try to select another
one at the same time.
So I select another one.
And now it's come
up with a pattern
that is asking me if I
want to apply this pattern.
If I just look
here on the right,
you can already see it's doing a
good job of actually extracting
that product ID.
So let's have a little
look at what's going on.
And you can see here, it's
looking for a pattern.
But obviously, the PID equals
is a part of my pattern.
So I'm just going to
take that part out.
There we go.
Put that down here.
So I'm going to say it
starts after the product ID.
And now you can see
in my new column,
I have quite a nice product ID.
So I can add that to the recipe.
And the only other thing
I'm going to do here
is I'm going to rename
this column to PID.
That was the fourth touch on
my Mac, if anyone uses Mac.
Don't all laugh at once.
So I've got my product IDs now.
Let's go back and have a
look at the other data set.
So here, I have
the sales scaled.
And let's see what
we can do with this.
So let's add a new recipe.
And now we're going to
go in and edit that.
Right.
So it hasn't done anything yet.
But what you can see
here on the sales
order lines is I've
basically got an array.
And I want to do
something with this array.
So I'm going to select
the whole column.
There we go.
And it's going to
give me some options.
It's going to say here, do I
want to delete this column?
Do I want to split it into
170 different columns?
No.
And here it has, do I want to
convert these arrays into rows?
Well, that looks quite good.
So now I've gone up in a kind
of order of magnitude here.
So I'm now at 35,000 rows.
So I think I'll keep
that as the first step.
But now, obviously, I
want to get to this data.
Let's try extracting it.
So let's click on this one.
Let's see what it's
going to suggest.
So it's going to
give me some options.
One of the options
here is to split.
Let's have a look
what happens there.
Well, that doesn't
look very good.
I should have some more.
And now I just click back.
Bear with me.
This is the demo effect.
So I'm quickly going
to do that again.
It's already done that for me.
So I need to find
something here that's going
to actually understand
these columns properly here.
So I already had the
right one selected.
And I've just done that again.
My excuses.
Third time lucky.
And I promise I will
disable the three finger
swipe on my Mac one day.
Which is actually a promise
I made after my last demo,
but I still haven't
got around to it.
I have another demo next week.
So if anyone is in
the audience who
knows me personally
wants to give me a prod,
that would be much appreciated.
Right.
Here we go using one finger.
So it's already splitting
those columns for me.
And one other thing.
I'm not going to
keep all of them now.
I just want to keep
a couple of them.
So I want to keep
the product key.
That's actually
all I want to keep.
So I'm just going to
delete the rest of these.
There we go.
And I'm going to add
that to the recipe.
It's just going to
take a few seconds.
Right.
So you see, now, I've
extracted that product key.
So what I've done, I
took that array of data.
We broke that array into rows.
We unnested it, effectively.
And we've now extracted the
product key column, which
is what we were looking for.
So the next thing I want
to do is join this data
with the previous data set.
So they come down here.
And I say, join.
And it's going to ask
me which data set do
I want to join it with.
And obviously, it's my ABC1.
Why am I not seeing that?
This flow, so there
we go, that one.
So I want to join it with that
one, preview selected data set.
And the first thing
I'm going to do here
is look at the join keys.
So the join keys--
it suggested a join.
But it's not very good.
So let's actually
go and look at that
and maybe change
that around a bit.
So let's edit that.
We don't want to join
on the cells or the key.
We want to join on
the product key.
And we're also
looking at customers.
So let's also join
with the customer key.
Yes, that's good.
And now give me one more.
And in this one, I want to join
the customer key with the user
ID.
And I'm going to save that.
And now I can look at
which columns I want.
So obviously, I don't
want all of these columns
here because these
have the user ID.
And I'll keep the product key.
I'll keep the customer key.
I'll take the order
date and the event time.
And let's just take
the total sales.
And then we can
add that to recipe.
So I've now joined those
two data sets together.
And apart from
going back and forth
between my screens because
of my sticky fingers,
we've actually managed
to join two data sets.
We've done some quite
complicated transformations.
We've extracted product
IDs with unnested data.
All that's left for me to do
now is to run this pipeline.
So I ran this earlier,
because it will actually
take a few minutes to run.
So let's have a look at
what that looked like.
Let's go back to--
so here's the next demo.
You can see the same pipeline.
And if you look
at jobs here, you
can see that I actually
ran this yesterday.
That was the pipeline.
Clip on the job ID.
We can have a look
at the recipe.
We can export-- there we go.
So it will give me an
overview of what I've done.
And so basically,
what's going to happen
when you run this
job, it's going
to create a Dataflow pipeline.
And we'll look at
Dataflow in a moment.
And that pipeline will get
executed in Google Cloud.
So it can really
scale to whatever
size it needs to to deal
with however much information
is coming at it.
And at the end, we
can actually send
that data to BigQuery or back
to Cloud Storage, for example.
Having it in BigQuery
would be super handy,
because then we can
actually do some analytics
and dashboarding from it.
But I hope this has
already given you
a good idea about
actually what you
might be able to achieve
with Dataprep, just
for actually looking
at data sets,
trying to understand them.
And at the end, we're
going to create a pipeline.
And that pipeline, you
can actually, then,
run, and then run it again.
So you can actually
have your data
appended each subsequent time.
So this should give you
a good indication of what
you can do with Cloud Dataprep.
So we're going to move on.
That particular job
that we were looking at
was actually about a batch job.
We had the data.
It was fixed.
We had a CSV that
was ready for us.
All the data was
already available for us
in BigQuery from
the transactions.
And now we're going to look
at how can we actually handle
some data that's
coming in as a stream.
And again, we're going to
be using Dataflow for this.
So I mentioned
Dataflow a few times
in that last presentation,
that it will--
the Dataprep itself
will actually
create a Dataflow
job which is going
to run to process your data.
So what is Dataflow?
And we're going to take
a use case of streaming.
So a few things about streaming.
A lot of the good systems that
are out there were built to--
they were designed to run
on distribution systems.
They weren't
necessarily designed
to be very friendly
for developers.
I mean Map produces
great, And Google,
we published a white
paper back on that,
produced somewhere early 2000.
It's a fundamental part
of a lot of the products
that we make at Google.
Also, Dataflow is also behind
BigQuery a certain level.
So it's a very important,
let's say, programming model.
But it's quite difficult as
a developer, especially when
you're working on small
tasks, or for the first time,
to get your head around.
And then we have some
additional problems.
We have batch, which
we just looked at,
which is really nice when
everything is already there,
and you can actually
take it, move on,
and you know the whole data
set that you're looking at
is complete.
So nothing is going
to come at you later.
You look at data that arrives
tomorrow because it's a batch.
It's a complete set.
So you know you're looking
at the whole picture.
In the case of
streaming, that's not.
You're just getting
single events,
or, let's say, little groups
of events coming at you.
And you don't actually know
if you've seen everything.
You don't even know
if everything's
in the right order.
So there's this whole notion
of processing time and event
time that can be quite difficult
to wrap your heads around.
So the first key
component in this--
and I actually should have
put a arctic slide in here--
the first key
component is actually
getting those events in.
So one of the things that
we're going to use is Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub is basically
message queuing.
It's a global system.
You can send literally
millions of messages per second
to the system if you need to.
It will guarantee you
at least once delivery
on any subscriber.
So it's called Pub/Sub,
so publish and subscribe.
So you have a publisher,
and you have a topic.
So your publisher is sending
this thing to a given topic.
And all your subscribers
on that topic--
you can have as many
as you want as well--
will sit there and
listen, and they
will receive messages, either
by a push or a pull mechanism.
And this is like--
think of if you're going
to create any pipeline
down stream, where
you're actually
going to be handling
streaming data,
Pub/Sub is a good place to
actually start buffering that.
Because if you turn that system
off, or it's not running,
you still need to be
able to get at the data.
Or when you want
to start up again,
you want to be able
to pick off the data
that you haven't yet processed.
So having a buffer in
between is very important.
A little bit about the
event processing time.
So in an ideal world, we would
see that diagonal line there,
that diagonal slope.
That would be perfect, you know.
Every time something happens,
we can process it instantly.
In reality, this
is not the case.
I will give an example now.
So in this example-- before I
explain what Apache Beam is--
in this example here, we have
event, a time on the x-axis
and the y-axis.
We have processing time.
And again, we have the dotted
line, the diagonal line,
which is the perfect line.
So number three is almost
in the perfect line.
Imagine these numbers
represent scores in a game.
And the only thing that we're
actually interested in doing
is, for this particular user--
and let's just say all this
data is from one user--
we are interested in
actually calculating a score
and sending it back
to him, or putting it
on a leaderboard somewhere.
So every time we get an
update with how many points
he's scored, so we
want to better process
that and represent
near real time,
on a dashboard, his score.
So three is really nice.
The event time and
the processing time
are very close to each other.
This doesn't really
happen very often.
what we do with
Dataflow, is we try
to create a heuristic
watermark, which
represents this kind of
relationship between the event
time and the processing time.
But it's based on the
information that it receives.
And it's not going
to be based on things
like if something comes
much later than I expected.
So score 9 here
came really late.
It happened just a
little bit after 12:01,
and we didn't process
it until 12:08.
So it came really late.
In fact, many different
scores that we received,
all the way up to this
score here, in the meantime,
we actually processed
those before we even
saw this one come in.
So that's problematic.
What we've done here--
so Apache Beam is the open
source project for Dataflow.
Dataflow is our managed
service to run Apache Beam.
So much like TensorFlow is an
open source project for machine
learning, and you can use Cloud
ML to run your machine learning
projects, do your training, or
to do your predictions there,
Dataflow will give
you the same ability
to take your Apache
Beam processing.
So it's a map produced like.
But the important
thing about Apache Beam
is unified batch and stream.
And what does unified
batch and stream mean?
Basically, we're
giving the semantics
to be able to deal with data,
regardless of whether it's
batch or stream.
So you don't need to go and
create two different pipelines.
And then the important
part, being able to do that,
is to be able to, first
of all, window your data.
So do you want to window in
fixed windows, in session time.
Do you want to window in
sliding windows, for example?
And also to be able
to deal with data
as it arrives late or early.
And in this particular
case here of nine,
we are dealing with a piece
of data that arrives late.
So that data comes in late.
We fire a trigger and
say, it's come in late.
And in that program,
it will do as well,
we also tell it, in our window,
if data comes at us late,
we would also like to
still be able to keep
all the data we have in the
window, so we can accumulate.
And then we will add
that, and we will
admit an update of the score.
So you don't have
to do it like that.
But that's just an example of
how you might want to do it.
So let's move on.
So for anyone has visited the
booth on the Instant Insights,
this might already
be familiar to you.
This is the architecture
I was just speaking about,
at the beginning.
So a Pub/Sub.
So we've got events happening.
Here, taxis are driving around.
And we're going to use data flow
to process that information.
And as that information
is processing,
we're going to do three things.
So all the solid arrows here
are actually streaming lines,
and all the dashed arrows,
these are batch lines.
So there are three things
going on in this pipeline.
The first one is we're
taking all the data that
comes at us, all the
events that we receive,
and we're sending them
straight to BigQuery,
so we can analyze them.
By doing that, all the data that
we already have in BigQuery--
so our data warehouse--
all the data that we already
there for this particular table
and all the data that's being
streamed in, we can query.
So we have the possibilities
to do real time querying
on the data and the historical
data, as it comes in.
And that's good because then
we can use something like data
prep to analyze the data.
We'll look at some
other stuff in a moment.
And once we've
done that, we could
use that data, for example,
to retrain our model.
And here, we would train a
model with intent to flow in
and Cloud ML-- the
service I just mentioned.
And once that model's
ready and been trained,
we could release a new
version to our serving part
of the Cloud ML space.
And you can have
different versions there,
which enables you to do
like AB testing on models.
And what we're going to do
in this particular example
is we're going to make a
prediction on how likely
the users in that taxi--
so what information do we have?
We have where the trip
started, where the trip ended,
how long the trip is taking so
far, and the number of people
that are in the taxi itself.
And we'll make
predictions on that,
on how likely they are to
respond to a given advert.
So one of those
adverse might be--
and you can see
the example, if you
want to see more of
this at the booth.
But one of these examples
might be three people,
driving in a taxi to the airport
might be interested in having
sushi before you fly.
I'm not taking responsibility
for the adverts.
Another example might be
someone driving from the airport
into town, as a single
person, and they
want to say, well, would
you like to visit this wine
bar because we know
this wine bar is very
popular with single
people that just
come into town, for example.
So that's the second
leg of this pipeline.
Now we have this information
still coming in here.
So we've sent a copy
of that information
to the data warehouse and
we're sending another copy
of that information--
we're calling the data
here to make a prediction.
And once we've made
that prediction,
we will send them
the recommendations
for the adverts.
And the last thing
that we're doing
is we're sending a small
aggregate of that data--
so we're aggregating
that data comes in--
so we can produce a heat map.
So think about a
dashboard that you
might have at the control
center to kind of show what's
going on at the moment--
how many taxis are driving
around at the moment?
Which locations are
they driving around in?
If you're having a conversation
with a potential client,
you can say, well,
look, this area
is really popular with taxis.
Would you like to have--
it could be a way
of actually trying
to promote your
advertising space in there.
So these adverts would
be, obviously, displayed
on a little screen in
the back of the taxi,
as they're driving around.
It's a very modern taxi.
So I'm going to just
show you a Dataflow very
briefly because I've got
to speed up a little bit.
It's not like me
to talk over time.
So this is the same pipeline.
So I'll just show you
a few features here.
One, this is the data
coming from Pub/Sub.
It's being read from Pub/Sub.
And we're sending
it to BigQuery.
And you can see, this is
running at the moment,
so, again, go to the
demo booth, if you want
to get more details on this.
And the other branch I want to
show you here is the ML call.
And one of the useful things
that you might want to do here
is just open up the logs.
And I've just
selected the ML call.
I'll just give it a second
for this to populate.
And you can see here that
there are requests being made
and there are
responses being given
for the different predictions.
So this is online, it's
running at the moment.
And please, have a look.
So that was Dataflow.
So we just looked about hard
to develop data pipelines.
A good thing just to
reinforce-- everything
that we've looked at the
moment is complete in managed.
There are no computers for
you to manage yourself.
If you run something
in Dataflow and you
put the right configuration--
like you use as many machines
as you need to--
it will scale up
and scale down to do
whatever it needs to do,
to get the job done.
The same with
BigQuery-- the data
prep is creating a Dataflow
pipeline in the background.
And Pub/Sub is a
completely managed service.
And you're just not concerned
by any number of machines
or anything there, it's just
the throughput that you want.
So this next part is about
hard to scale and operate
on Big Data applications.
So let's have a look at
some of the challenges.
These are some of
the challenges.
I'm not going to
read them all not,
but, basically, this is
where you want to be.
You want to spend your time
on insights and analytics.
You don't want to
spend your time
on doing performance
tuning, resource
provisioning-- all that stuff.
So let's move on.
Let's look at those
three applications again.
I just, basically,
foretold this slide.
But Pub/Sub for ingestion,
Dataflow for processing,
and for analysis, BigQuery.
Again, no sharding, no capacity
guessing, no idle resources,
et cetera.
These are managed services.
And so the BigQuery is
using standard SQL notation,
so you don't have to go and
learn a new SQL dialect.
There are a few add-ons for
unnesting data, for example.
I'm sure that will be talked
about in the next conversation.
I can show just that
very, very briefly here.
So here is a row in the table.
And here are the
nested rows, let's say.
The repeated rows.
So we have a few extensions
to deal with that.
And Dataflow-- that all
important processing part--
because this is where the magic
is happening, where you're
actually transforming your data,
and filtering it, and applying
all sorts of complicated stuff.
This is where your
business logic is.
You can write that Apache Beam.
That's open source.
You can run that on Spark,
you can run it on Flink,
on your own Hadoop clusters--
as it's running at the moment--
or if you run it by us, we'll
run it in a managed service
and you won't have
to worry about all
those things on the right.
This line here is basically
saying a little bit
about how much Google
has been involved
in open source and Big
Data technology, so things
like GFS and MapReduce.
These are two white papers
from, I said, early 2000.
There you go-- 2004.
And these were
basically white papers
that really kind of instigated
the whole Hadoop conversation,
let's say.
Our externalized version
of Dremel is BigQuery.
Basically, we built
BigQuery because MapReduce
wasn't fast enough, nor
was it friendly enough.
So one of those things-- we
want to spend time on insights,
we don't want to spend time
writing complicated pipelines,
if we don't have to.
So with BigQuery, you're
just using standard SQL.
And you can run,
literally, a petabyte query
in a couple of minutes.
It's going to be an expensive
query because that's
a lot of data to
process, but if you
want to run a petabyte
in a couple of minutes,
it's completely
possible with BigQuery.
So another challenge
is silos of analytics.
So how can we avoid those?
Well, we can avoid
those like we avoid
most things-- by separating
out responsibilities.
In this case, separating
storage and compute.
On the lower line here,
we have storage options--
so cloud storage,
object storage files.
We have BigQuery.
And BigQuery, in this case--
when we're talking about
BigQuery storage--
so BigQuery has two parts--
the processing and the storage.
And BigQuery storage is
really optimized storage.
It's column optimized
storage, so you can really
get great performance
from your queries.
And the last one here
is Cloud Bigtable.
This is our own, internal
version of what--
in the external
version, for example,
in the Hadoop community, you
would see something like HBase.
Bigtable itself
isn't open source,
but we do supply an API
which is HBase compliant.
So if you would like to
move from Bigtable table
into HBase, to running your own
HBase cluster in the future,
you could do that completely.
And we have an API, which
means that how you communicate
with Bigtable would
be the same as how
you communicate with HBase.
So this is storage options.
On the top line, we
have the processing.
So we just looked at Dataflow.
BigQuery analytics-- so this is
basically the part of BigQuery
where you're actually writing
queries and processing
your data.
And Dataproc-- I don't have time
to speak about Dataproc today,
but Dataproc is, basically, our
Spark and Hadoop, The Google
Cloud way.
You can spin up a cluster
in under 90 seconds.
You can, basically, start
thinking of MapReduce,
and Spark jobs, and Hive
jobs, or Pig scripts
in the terms of a job
as opposed to a cluster.
You're built by the minute.
Because we can spin up
and tear down so quickly,
it completely changes
how you look at that.
So if you're running
Hadoop at scale
and you're interested
to know more about this,
please contact any of us
or any of our partners.
We'd be happy to talk
you through that.
In all three of
these cases here,
what we're basically
doing-- we're
giving the options to
be able to interact
with any of these
processing units
with any of the storage units
underneath, as you can see.
So that really gives
you the ability
to kind of separate where
you're storing things
and make it available for
all your different processing
environments.
Crowd ML engine--
I said this is our managed
service for running TensorFlow.
I'm just going to
leave that there.
That's kind of a
bit vague, isn't it?
But what we're basically
trying to say here
is that what we're doing on
the data processing side,
we're doing on the
machine learning
side as well with TensorFlow.
So if you think,
in this discussion,
TensorFlow is taking the
same spot as Apache Beam.
It's an open source project.
You can run the way you want.
If you want to run
them by us, we'll
make sure there's good security,
good performance, good cost.
Then we have a managed service
to actually help you do that.
And now we're going to look at
some of the data science tools
that you might need.
So the first one we're
going to look at is Datalab.
A quick hands up, again, if
you've used a Jupyter Notebook?
Or a Zeppelin?
Or IPython?
So great.
That's a fair number of hands.
So for those of you
that don't know it,
a Jupyter Notebook is,
basically, a way in which
an analyst or a
data scientist might
want to write his
code in Python or R
to actually start
processing data.
And whether that's actually
doing some analysis
or is creating a
machine learning model,
it's a really interactive and
collaborative way of working.
I will show you.
And we have a managed option,
which is called Datalab.
And the nice thing
about Datalab is
it's based on IPython
Notebooks as well,
and it basically brings
all of the connections
that you need with all the
Google products to one space,
and it has some more
collaboration options.
I will show that in a second.
So the first thing
I need to do is--
let me just close this.
I'll do it from scratch.
So if I go to my VMs, you'll
see I have a VM here running
called BigData Workshop.
I'm going to use the
Cloud Shell and I'm
going to connect to this VM.
There we go.
So I'm going to call Datalab.
And if you didn't have a Datalab
instance, like I have here,
you could, instead of writing
the next word, connect,
you would write create.
You can also give
a machine type,
if you want to have a
slightly bigger machine type.
Worth noticing here-- the
machine type that I used
is actually too big,
so it's actually
giving me a recommendation.
So all the stuff that we tried
to do outside of Google Cloud
to get off you that
ability, we tried
to do inside Google Cloud
as well, and, obviously,
other Google products.
So here, it's giving
me a recommendation,
based on my usage, that I
could use a cheaper machine
and save some money.
So that's good to know.
But here, I'm just
going to connect.
So Datalab, Connect.
And I just need to
type the name now.
So BigData Workshop.
That will set up the SSH tunnel.
And this little
web preview here--
I could select here and
actually click Open Page.
I would have it running here.
Once I click and open, I
basically get my Datalab.
This is kind of the menu page.
And here is a notebook.
You see Connection Failed
because, at the time,
it wasn't connected.
If I just refresh this now,
you'll see that it's all fine.
And we're going to
run very, very quickly
through this notebook because I
do want to show you Data Studio
as well.
And I've got four minutes
and 48 seconds left.
Here we go.
Please, can I have five more?
Basically, the nice
thing about this
is that you can combine
markup with actual work
that you're doing
in different cells.
So this first cell
isn't too interesting.
I'm just importing something.
But the second is really nice.
The second cell here,
I'm going to actually ask
me to describe one of
the tables in BigQuery.
The language that I'm
using here is Python.
If you see these two percentage
signs, that's basically telling
Datalab, this is a magic cell.
So if I use two percentage
lines, the whole cell is magic.
If I use one percentage
sign, then it's
just that line that is magic.
So it's basically saying,
go use the plumbing that's
already done in the background.
And that plumbing will
allow me, in this case,
to connect to BigQuery
without having
to write all that stuff
because it's in my project.
I had the right permissions.
And it will describe
the table for me.
So there we go.
It describes the table.
And I get a quite
nice description
about all the different
columns I have.
And here's an example of
some of the nested data.
So here, I have hits.
And under hits, I would have,
actually, repeats of this.
I'm going to go down and do
a little bit of querying.
So I'm going to
get to the bottom,
in the interest of time.
I'm going to run this query.
And then, basically,
what I've done
by running this query here--
I haven't actually run it yet.
I've just told it to get ready.
And I basically say, when I call
conversions, run this query.
So here, we are going
to run the query.
And I'm actually going to
say, now execute and show
me the data.
And it's going to
show me the data.
But I would like to do
something a little bit more
useful with this, to make it
a little bit more visualized.
And I'm going to use the sankey.
So here, I'm running a sankey.
And this data set
that we're looking at
is conversion on
analytics, so it's very
similar to that first use case.
It's like, OK, given
that you start off
on this page on the
website and you move to--
we want you to be here, so,
after the shopping cart, what's
the conversion, for example?
And here we can
see, for the sankey,
if I start off with the product
page, so many are abandoned
and so many are completed.
So it gives me good
visual representation.
If I start off on the
home page, the proportion
between abandoned and completed
is slightly different.
That seems to be
working slightly better,
but more people are actually
landing on the product
page than the home page.
You can draw your
own conclusions,
but this is a really
good way of interacting.
One thing to mention is
that when you run Datalab,
it's already tied into Git.
So you have un-Gits here.
And an un-Git will
actually allow
you to connect to the
Git instance, which
is running on your Google
Cloud project or, if you want,
you can connect to
a GitHub instance.
And I can actually use this
to check in the work I do.
So if I'm trying to share
this with multiple people,
they can all work on that and
receive the latest updates.
And all of that's out the box.
So once you just
basically do that Datalab,
Create, and give it a name, you
can start working in Datalab,
use that machine, and
people can work together
to make useful things, and
share that amongst each other.
So this is a good way
for a data scientist
or an analyst to
actually explore
data or start writing a model.
And the last one
I'm going to show--
so I'm actually almost on time--
is Data Studio.
So when you run a query
on us, a big query,
we charge you for the query,
the size of the query,
and we charge you
for the storage.
We have a product which is
similar to other dashboard
products out there.
It's a little bit more simple,
but it has one amazing feature,
in my personal opinion.
Well, it has two
amazing features.
First of all, it's free.
So you can actually
use this and you can
you give it to as many
users as you need to.
They can all work
together on that.
And you're only paying for
the queries that are running.
So here is an example of
a dashboard being created.
And the first thing
that I'm going to show--
I'm going to show
you some View mode.
So this is what the dashboard
would look like if someone
was actually looking at it.
You can select
the date here, you
can look at what's
going on here.
This is all kind of
standard dashboard stuff.
I will show you, very
quickly, one thing.
And that one thing that I want
to show you is collaboration.
This is the part I,
personally, think is amazing.
What we do a Google with
things like G Suites,
with Sheets, and Documents,
if you've ever used them,
the ability to work together,
at the same time on a document--
we also have that in our
dashboarding product.
So you can come
into this product--
and I've actually got
two screens running here.
So at the moment,
this other user here--
you can see that's not me.
That's Google Account
Instant Insights.
And here, that's where you
can see a nice photo of me.
So it's me, obviously.
My name's Robert.
Hi.
So this user here doesn't
have the ability to edit it.
So I'm going to change
the sharing rules.
Let me have a quick look.
So if I go Share the Report,
I can see here, by Advanced,
I've already shared it
with the other user,
but they can only view it.
If I say that they
can edit it as well--
save the changes, click Done.
You can see now, if
I refresh this page,
that I can also edit.
Come on.
There we go.
So I can also edit on this page.
And I'm out of time.
But one moment.
I'm going to add an extra
page to this report.
I've just done that.
I'm going to add a new chart.
Let's take a bar chart.
Where are you?
Here.
And add a bar
chart, for example.
It's already going to
come up with a suggestion.
I'm going to try
adding it again.
OK.
Demo effect, right at the end.
Yeah.
Well, while you're refreshing,
let's go to this user.
Maybe you're OK.
So let's add a bar chart.
There we go.
I added a bar chart.
It's already giving
me a suggestion.
Obviously, you can go here
and do all the kind of stuff
that you would normally
do with a bar chart.
And you can see
here, in real time,
that this user can also start
working on that bar chart.
So the only thing I'm going
to do here is to say, Style.
And I'm going to say,
make it horizontal.
And if I go back,
it's horizontal.
So there are two users
working together,
creating the same dashboard.
And with that, I'll let you
get ready for your next talk.
Thank you very much.